[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors comment s'organisent les mariages
pour nous fournir justement pardon les
plus belles d'informations possibles
comment gérer une exclusivité et faire
face à la concurrence comment les
paparazzi infiltrent les mariages
combien de temps de préparation ça
nécessite pourquoi est-ce que parfois
certains arrivent à rester complètement
secret justin bieber star mondiale s'est
marié personne n'a su karine ferri star
un peu moins mondial s'est mariée tout
le monde l'a su pourquoi on va tout
comprendre
regardez nabila et thomas do you do et
philippa comme françois-xavier demaison
et anaïs qui y est la saison 2010 9 des
mariages est ouverte des mariages
confidentiel à part quelques vidéos
comme celle ci publié par les invités
sur les réseaux sociaux
quand elle se marie la hantise des stars
ce sont les paparazzi le meilleur moyen
de s'en protéger c'est donc de ne rien
dire c'est ce qu'a fait ed sheeran qui
s'est marié dans le plus grand secret la
date n'avait pas filtré personne n'avait
l'info hormis les quelques proches qui
étaient invités si ed sheeran a réussi à
rester discrets d'autres en revanche
préfèrent jouer à fond la carte de la
presse people et vendre l'exclusivité de
leur union à des magazines
c'est le cas de l'acteur anglais idris
elba et de sa femme top model sabrina
d'or qui ont ouvert les portes de leur
mariage au vob britannique
trois jours de festivités dont le
journal a raconté tous les détails lieu
de la cérémonie cet hôtel de luxe à
marrakech marque de la robe de la mariée
haute couture italienne
on a même eu le menu une belle promo
donc pour les marques citées qui en
échange ont certainement fait des petits
cadeaux aux couples et moyennant
l'exclusivité une coquette somme pour
s'offrir un beau
h et puis il y a les célébrités qui sauf
qu'elles ne pourront pas couper aux
indiscrétions de la presse c'est le cas
de la princesse de monaco charlotte
casiraghi qui a épousé le producteur
dimitri rassam fils de carole bouquet
pour être tranquille le couple princier
a fait cette photo officielle relayée
par tous les médias
il a laissé aussi filtrer quelques
clichés pris de très loin par des
photographes pour ainsi dire tolérer des
photos qui peuvent valoir cher alors
comment les rédactions décroche tel leur
scoop
voilà ça va faire parler on a commencé
donc cette le même partenaire presto les
mariages de karine ferri au passage
lembras mouassa deux filles j'aime
beaucoup je veux qu'elle a sa place au 4
avril bien il progresse bien et voilà je
l'embrasserai fort et elle s'est mariée
avec seb gourcuff le footballeur je
préfère embrasser gourcuff 1 wiimote et
le sujet comment as tu pu avoir des
belles photos est-ce que tu étais invité
non non non je n'étais pas invitée
j'étais pas le seul bien mais combien de
cette agence à 5 agences je dire à une
dizaine de paparazzi sur tous les toits
autour de l'église
ouais donc voilà il y avait plus de
place sur les toits dans les armes non
mais ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que dans
un mariage il ya 140 150 invités il ya
énormément de prestataires de services
les gens autour de l'église
ouais sur la petite place du village la
police municipale est prévenu il ya d
arrêter tout ça fait des centaines et
des centaines de gens courant donc c'est
impossible de passer au vert municipal a
par exemple commencé à faire des
barriérage et radis qui donne des infos
je dis que ça commence à se savoir
n'aura bien sûr il ya des barrières
qu'il ya de la sécurité qui se baladent
que tout ça est organisée qui a beaucoup
d'invités beaucoup de gens qui
travaillent sur le mariage mais comment
se voient concrètement tu fait les bains
on a des fuites
on a des fuites donc on a des sources
qui sont soit dans leur tour à choix
parmi les échos très moche ou mensuels
pour la belle photo pl ensuite quand la
belle fête au camp quand quand c'est une
église
il ya un moment si la mariée veut
rentrer et sortir de l'église comme tout
le monde
eh ben
elle est exposée donc il suffit d'être
soit dans des fenêtres soit sur un toit
soit dans un arbre peu importe avoir une
vue de hauteur il faut savoir aussi que
à l'intérieur
là c'était là c'était comment à l'église
n'est par exemple les mairies les
mairies s'est ouvert au public on ne
peut pas interdire l'entrée d'une mairie
c'est à dire qu'une star qui se
marierait en fermant les portes et en
essayant de se marier en dehors des
heures du mariage
on pourrait faire annuler le mariage
d'accord ça veut dire que n'importe qui
peut rentrer dans le mariage s'installer
avec avec les gens franc d'un petit un
iphone et faire les photos de la signer
alors juste question est à présent bien
que ce prix c'est quoi le mariage de
plus compliqué où le foot a failli me te
faire sortir par la sécurité le match de
plus fort que t'es fait un américain ou
kim kardashian à versailles donc le
matin j'avais faire en hélicoptère quand
elle avait été dans la propriété de
c'était je ne sais plus et est un hélico
toi là j'étais en est libre elle j'étais
en hélico pour l'ailé quand ils ont fait
les photos de famille de mariage je suis
arrivé au dernier moment je suis
descendu à 80 mètres d'ankara j'étais
face à eux ils m'ont tous regardé du
coup la photo l'algérien nico qui
descendra probablement dans ces
professionnels
sachez que je suis à l'extérieur de les
capteurs les pieds sur le pas de harnais
la chine ya trois doberman essart et
garde du corps gaza sont déjà 80 m haies
et est le seul oscar l'hélico il y avait
il avait installé une zone d'exclusion
pour l'hélicoptère à versailles et balla
déguisements militaire et on est rentré
dans le versailles
moi j'aimerais j'adorais passer une
semaine avec toi juste voir comment tu
fais je vois ma gazon je la paie pour
devrait me dit je peux pas te parler
chose une poubelle
[Rires]
mais quelle vie myriam sks qu'il ya des
dvd des espèces que vous négociez
parfois franchement soul sous le manteau
on va dire des mariages avec happy paul
carril ferry ou d'autres en disant voilà
on fait la une
tu lui donnes tout ça on finance ton
mariage alors non c'est pas trop nous la
presse people a souvent quand quand ils
viennent nous voir moi ça m'est arrivé
quand même que certains people viennent
nous voir je positive peut citer leurs
noms mais bon voilà pour renégocier me
demande une blinde on demande des 100
des cent cinquante mille euros
ils veulent financer tous leurs mariages
n'ont en général et voilà ici puis ils
ont des exclus avec des magazines voilà
vous êtes plutôt de voler en fait c'est
pas très clair
c'est clairement je préfère parle je
préfère pas de photos volées parce
qu'après j'ai les jets les commissions
avant de voler un hélicoptère qui arrive
avec un mec de denrées qui prend des
photos des règles concernant autorités
il faut savoir que les amener à
l'intérieur de l'église si on les passe
bas on va payer très cher juridiquement
françois xavier et karine ferri là ça va
vous coûter de l'argent magazine novès
cave et pour le coup je pense que voyage
je pense que ça va dérange pas qu'avec
ferrini ça la dérange pas que si c'est
pas trop dérangeant que ce n'est pas une
photo dans dans sa chambre je pense
qu'elle nous regarder quels vous emmerde
qu'elle va tech je peux bien élections
cette année datent de guillaume qui est
très intéressant guillaume tassé
quelqu'un on peut citer non ah oui c'est
elle marche de nos digues ne sont jamais
su qu'elle est mariée c'était il ya une
quinzaine d'années je lui ai dit écoute
j'avais clairement de faire sans relâche
riche pour une émission people à
l'époque et je lui ai dit écoute si tu
veux ce qu'on fait c'est que tu tu
jouerais film et en mariage je vais le
faire d'une manière très jolie n'y aura
pas de vol y aura rien donc j'avais
demandé à bertrand de mettre un micro
dans son
noeud de cravate pour que l'église est
bien le oui au moment du mariage et je
leur avais dit après en contrepartie
tout ça je vous emmène huit jours dans
une île magnifique des antilles pendant
quatre jours vous me donnez tout ça qu
on va vous filmer au réveil le matin le
soir la plage à la la on s'aime c'est
beau l'amour faisant l'amour dans l'eau
sur le sur le truc c'est génial et du
coup et les quatre autres jours elles
étaient tranquilles avait dit oui et
bien sûr mais n'y avait pas des
changements
c'était pas un échange d'argent accord
d'aller c'était un truc et du coup elle
avait elle a eu le film de son mariage
qui était très bien filmé que j'entends
lui crée alors pour avoir des photos de
mariage quand même parce qu'on parle de
paparazzi mais en fait il faut quand
même se méfier beaucoup des invités je
reçois beaucoup d'appels et de mails des
invités qui veulent vendre des photos
d'un mariage où ils ont été invités je
me souviens à l'époque ensuite pas du
mariage d'intermarché pas de vide ça je
peux le dire
et s'ils sont malades ils avaient
affrété un avion pour aller au maroc se
marier en secret il a vu la date au
dernier moment etc
j'ai au moins eu quatre ou cinq invités
des chiffres différents c'est bien moins
vite et qui moi qui m'ont rappelé pour
vendre les photos de mariage vous avez
tous frais payés des photos de moins en
avance le mariage de benjamin castaldi
avec flavie flament j'y étais et on a on
devait tous laissé notre portable à
l'entrée on est sûr qu'il n'ya aucune
photo parce qu'ils avaient eux aussi
avaient des dossiers leur mariage avec
ce qu'il est et vendues au magazine des
pensionnés ne fait pas très beau
sébastien vallée lialores mariage parce
que ça qui va venir quand même eu dans
les nations